[موسيقى]
في نهايه القرن التاسع عشر اعتقد غالبيه
العلماء انهم وصلوا لنهايه العلم في مجال
الفيزياء لياتي اكتشاف الذره ليثبت ان ذلك
العلم بدا من جديد هذا الجديد اثمر عن
اختراع الطاقه النوويه فكيف حدث ذلك
شهدت الفتره بين اواخر القرن الثامن عشر
وبدايه القرن التاسع عشر اكتشاف
اليورانيوم والاشعاع المؤين ثم خدمت
الصدفه هنري بكرل ليكتشف ان املاح كبريتات
اليورانيوم تصدر اشعاعات مشابهه للاشعه
السينيه في عام
1899 صنف ارنست ثلاثه انواع من الاشعاع
اسماها الفا وبيتا وجاما قبل ان تعلن ماري
كوري عن اكتشافها للريدوم الذي استخدم
لاحقا في المجالات الطبيه كما حددت الكتله
الذريه له وابتكرت مصطلحه النشاط الاشعاعي
بين العامين
1913 و
1928 وضعت مدرسه كوبنهاجن بقياده نيلزبور
اسس ميكانيكا الكم ونموذجا لشكل الذره
المكون من
والكترونات والنيوترونات فانتعشت ابحاث
دراسه الذره وخصوصا اليورانيوم ففيما وجدت
ايرين كوري وفريدريك ان انشطار اليورانيوم
ينتج جسما يتمتع بخصائص اللانثوم القابل
للاحتراق في الهواء اقترح اوتوهان وفريد
في المانيا ان النشاط الاشعاعي يطلق ايضا
النيوترونات اضافيه قد تسبب انشطارا في
نوايورانيوم اخرى وتطلق طاقه هائله انتعش
العمل على ابحاث الطاقه الذريه عالميا لكن
الابحاث في المانيا اخذت مجرى عسكريا تحت
قيادتها هتلر ما دفع الرئيس الامريكي
لانتاج السلاح النووي فعمل علماء من كندا
وامريكا يتقدمهم انريكو فيرمي الذي قام
ببناء اول مفاعل نوويا وعدد من العسكريين
على اول قنبله نوويه حملت اسمه
وتم تفجيرها في صحراء نيو مكسيكو صباح
السادس عشر من يوليو عام
1945 قبل ان يتم في السادس والتاسع من
اغسطس اسقاط قنبلتي
وفاتمان في هيروشيما وناجازاكي
اليابانيتين حيث قتل ما يصل الى 250 الف
شخص وانتهت الحرب العالميه الثانيه خلال
الستينيات والسبعينيات من القرن الماضي تم
بناء الكثير من المفاعلات النوويه لتوليد
الكهرباء برياده امريكيه لكن ومع حلول
العام 2020 اصبح يجري الحديث عن النهضه
النوويه والخطط الطموحه لبناء اساطيل
كبيره لتلبيه الطاقه المتزايده حول العالم